John how are you this morning oh man so
much to talk about I haven't slept I
mean Paulie not signing the scorecard
has just kept me up for days
how would you roll you love you love the
game of golf
you're very good golfer miniature golf
where Paulie didn't sign his scorecard
and you would have ruled how not a
problem that scorecard should be damp
from alcohol whatever you choose and
have cigar ashes all over it where the
pencil won't even work all right here we
go now let's recap what we saw last
night where do you want to start with
last night
well there's so much to digest here well
obviously the three critical place the
block charge called that they go to
replay
George Hill missing a free throw and
then the jr. debacle also a Kevin Love
foul on Steph Curry to put them up one
was a terrible foul you can't get a
touch foul at that stage of the game
that I put the Warriors up one if he
doesn't final Steph Curry
George Hill makes one free throw and
they probably lead one-nothing yeah I
was surprised with the call on Kevin
Love there hey I just John you played in
the game you played in the NBA for a
long time
I just don't know if we're evolving when
it comes to officiating the game it
doesn't feel like that I don't know what
a foul is and isn't anymore and then
we'll get to the blocking in the charge
goal yeah I agree I don't know I
couldn't see from my angle you know
maybe just a little touch foul I don't
think it had an effect on what's going
on but it's so technical for these
officials now back in the day it just
used to be it they'd officiate on
advantage disadvantage that was the big
thing like if a guy found the guy and it
didn't put the guy to disadvantage and
he still scored they let it go and it
was all about advantage disadvantage
you're not going to bail out a guy if
there's a three on one break and he
takes a charge when the guy passes it to
the wing that's a bailout
that's a guy to disadvantage that tries
to get an advantage and it doesn't
happen and they don't do that anymore
that's just the fact of the matter
that's the way it is and it's very
difficult to officiate but you know when
you talk about this blog charge thing
that the trigger to go to the replay is
always been a problem for me I never
know exactly how they can go over there
to do that all you see is players waving
their index finger coaches waving their
index finger and these officials make
calls and then they just walk over there
and they take a look but I I guess if I
had to provide a problem with it now I
thought it was a block and I thought it
was a block in real time and then when I
watched it again I said it's such a
bang-bang play they're not gonna reverse
that they're just gonna review and see
if LeBrons in the restricted area and we
realized he wasn't in the restricted
area so I'm thinking they're gonna call
charge and you play on and then they
reversed it I just didn't think that
there was enough evidence where you go
yep that's a block not a charge I had a
real problem with it a real problem with
him you yeah I thought once they went
and looked at they'd probably leave it
the same I agree that I thought it was a
block I thought he was still sliding a
bit to the left but the fact of the
matter is he was 2 feet outside that
restricted area so what you should be
able to go to the trigger for is what
happened was Tony Brothers was going to
call a block yeah Kenny Mauer was
calling a charge now if you have two
officials that differ on a call then you
should be able to go to the monitor if
one guy says hey I think it's a block
and the other guy says charge go to the
monitor fine get it right it's a huge
play it's under a minute to go in the
game yeah but that should be the trigger
not not getting a bail out by saying
he's close to the restrictor he wasn't
even close
yeah just I didn't want to see the game
decided on those kind of calls and and I
I'm in a LeBron apologist I'll say that
up front here but it doesn't feel like
he gets he doesn't get the star
treatment as consistent or as often as
he should I thought he had a clean pick
on Durant I thought when he went to the
hoop he got fouled and then you had the
block now you know charge now let's you
know have it go back to apply my in my
tomb
human apologist here for LeBron in that
sequence no I'll agree with that I think
he doesn't put the onus on the officials
enough late in ball games
III think there's a something in his
head he does not want to go to the line
in the crunch time late in ball games he
takes jumpers 90% of the time as opposed
to going to the rim even on the last
play when he throws it's George Hill
he's standing out at the top of the key
he wasn't trying to take that ball to
the rim which he did it will for the
whole game he's got to put his head down
he had Steph Curry on him again go to
the rim yeah you know he doesn't go to
the rim enough I think at the end of all
games what do you think of jr. Smith
answer I've never heard a guy just
complete flat-out lie to the media right
out of the game no I mean he's
completely lying he told the bran James
I thought we were ad he dribbled it out
like he was dribbling out the game not
caught with dribbling out there to call
it time out what are you kidding me but
John how does it work how does it work
in the huddle because that was another
thing this wasn't just up and down the
floor you had you had a timeout where
you hit you have a reset right where
where you have an assistant coach who
says here's the deal right is that what
happens in these NBA Huddle's right well
no you know you're down one you you he
made one I don't I don't know what are
you supposed to go up and go junior of
the games tied like what you just sat
here and watched the guy tied the game
and it's not it's you know people say
put it on LeBron and like come on like
you got to know that that's the case
now maybe once even if he's dribbling
out you can't call a timeout maybe he's
got a master plan I don't know but he
had no plan if you're calling call the
timeout as soon as you get the rebound
well yeah but he should have gone up
yeah how about Kevin Durant just getting
a little nudge in his back and giving up
the rebound to Junior Smith that's a
terrible play to come on junior could
have been
hero jr. could have been the hero could
have been but yeah no wait now now we
might not have Tristan Thompson or Kevin
Love okay yeah I'm gonna make you the
you're the Commissioner do you suspend
Kevin Love for Game two for leavin Ben
well hey David Stern is in the
entertainment business and he suspended
Amar'e Stoudemire
well that's David Adams I was quite the
different Commissioner than mr. stern
look the bottom line is it's black and
white if you go on the floor and you're
not in the ball game and there's a fight
you're out yeah Russell Westbrook did
the same thing against Utah earlier this
year in the city in the playoffs was at
the scores table a fight breaks out he
steps on the floor they say well because
he was checking in we're gonna find him
ten thousand he's not out the next game
so what do you want to do with Kevin
Love he clearly was out of the game he
walked on the floor he said he wanted to
talk to an official about the ejection
of Tristan Thompson is why he entered
the floor but it doesn't matter why you
entered you know you went on the floor
yeah they don't care you know they don't
care what your Excuse is but why was
Tristan Thompson thrown out of the game
well it looked like he kind of came up
with a high elbow to to Livingston as he
was upset that it was a 10-point game
and there was one second the shot clock
and he threw up a shot like let's not be
so sensitive people
the game's over yes he didn't take a
three he didn't go in and dunk the ball
and try to rub it in that you guys lost
the game Steve Kerr always told me just
look if we have if the shot clock is not
going to go off by the time our
possession is over I don't care what
we're up we shoot the ball there's
nothing wrong with that what would what
would we be talking about today if Jerry
Smith actually puts that ball up in
scores that the Cavs take Game one and
LeBron puts up to 51 yeah well again it
was this enough competition for LeBron
James for all those people that say well
eight straight finals and they're not
playing anybody and he's not that great
oh stop
and even Steve curse
you know Michael's former teammate I
mean he's playing at a high level as
high level as he's ever seen and you
know not that he's saying that this is
something that is even past Michael
Jordan but you know Steve's
acknowledging what the obvious is and
saying it that LeBron is playing at a
very very high level so you know
probably higher than anybody who's ever
played in the postseason in a recent
model it's just it's it's mind-boggling
I mean he didn't get a whole lot of help
I mean Kevin Love does get 21 last night
but other than that there wasn't much
and they should have won the ball game
at Golden State in Game one you know
it's just that backcourt was terrible
harab wasn't great no terrible what do
you think happens in Game two
well III kind of think it's kind of like
a NCAA tournament when a big favorite
sneaks by a lower seed and you know Game
two it's it's all about the antennas are
up and boy guys we got we gotta pay
attention to detail and focus and play
better because the lawyers really were
pretty bad defensively for most of the
night and they know they're fortunate
they got to win and so I think they play
a much more spirited game on the
defensive end and I could see them
running away what's game - are you
playing golf out there I am Sam Cisco
golf club leaving well that's not fair
it's one of my favorite places man isn't
it beautiful
I love it I love it you step back in
time with that place I love it yeah I'll
bring my tailor-made clubs out there
because I love tailor-made
and listen to your shameless promotions
for her Callaway Paulie said I think
Odyssey putter 73 times after his
victory at John John that's called a
partnership I love it I love it it's
great stuff I mean if you want to play
with TaylorMade that's okay I mean good
for you I'm trying to get my shameless
plug in there too yeah all right now
somebody just text you there to say
thank you for the TaylorMade mention
yeah yeah yeah all right well I'm just
gonna hook you up with Callaway and take
care of you but that's okay you play
with your own fear product and I found
you oh it's quality stuff I love the
rogue is a very nice driver yeah it's
it's the number one driver in golf the
John oh my god have a good weekend John
see you thank you bye
that's John Barry for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]